people think soap operas here in America
have convoluted plots telenovelas are
really out there yes really out there in
terms of plot and I found a still from
your character in one telenovela and I
don't know
great what the context is of this
storyline like what can you tell us
what's happening here so okay that's
don't yell at Amaya and in that
character she was a savage she had she
grew up in the wild she grew up in the
wild and the tree she had poor parenting
her dad was an alcoholic her mom
abandoned her you know like what
parenting doesn't poor parenting means
yeah poor parenting means I you know had
to share sneakers with someone it
doesn't mean I grew up in the jungle and
you became like you were like an animal
yeah so I was an animal and I had like
animal friends and then as my cousin
discovered me that in the trees awful of
mud and whatnot and he you know
domesticated me and taught me how to eat
and read and and be a proper lady okay
and that's was all part of the
telenovela yes that was my story art
okay you won't believe my story art
please don't like I can't I can't give
it away here it's just insane and and
and I was finding out about what where
this would go and here's what they told
me and you can confirm this because you
really worked in telenovelas they said
that the audience really controls the
story how the story turns out is that
true that if they that they like
something they you see more of that
character if they don't like something
terrible things happen to the characters
that right yes absolutely so I think
it's a very democratic way of watching
television because you get exactly what
you want and we're two days off err but
have been killed a long time ago I don't
know justice oh so what happens is that
they're watching and you get your
writers get instant feedback yeah
basically they go to the forums and
they're test groups and the ratings if
the ratings spike when they see
such-and-such together they write
towards that but when they start seeing
that the villain is being you know ii
mean they put her in a car accident they
make her blind for a couple weeks and
then you feel bad for her
then you know she regains her eyesight
but then still plays that she's blind so
she could get her way and she turns back
you know evil again so in a weird way
did you ever see anybody like the
writers go after an actor they didn't
like yeah that that's like Tom Morello
101 you always say what's on the script
that's that's number one rule yeah I
this kind of played my father and one he
just refused to say what was written and
the writers wrote a memo like in the
front page of the script and said hey
you better start saying the lines if not
you might not be around and he laughed
it off and then they killed him off two
days later and his character was just
gone my dad just died
he disappeared your take just said if
anyone just tuning in no the writers
didn't kill her real bad people tuned in
late you know what happened that would
have been a good warning to the actor
you you just say what's on the script
yeah you guys ever fear of your writers
because I certainly do I stick to what's
on the paper our writers have no power
yeah we there now our writers are part
of a state program we get tax breaks
yeah as long as we have them back at the
penitentiary yeah we're fine
you